[Music]
Quaker simple condition as usual while
citizens
government authority to fill out the
culture that they govern the evaluation
call probably outcome
Lajja Lunas innocent abused importance
but not the register momentum not very
stated demo cannot affirm persisted
legendas estimate sutorius Kalama garlic
zo pnc mucho de la madre tierra porque
esta be Boris
your boolean watching what you do
[Music]
I didn't mention I was ditching me
with
see
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sake on very excited to be
talking about the 12th film and so much
more we have two of the nine cofounders
of the Liceo foundation joining us on
the show Oliver Gerrard and Sophie moon
Basin hello thank you so much for coming
on the show
well we're very grateful thank you thank
you for having us
it's great thank you thank you I'm so
excited for this conversation thank you
thank you thank you
Olivier Sophie thank you okay let's give
a background to those that don't know
Olivia and Sophie are two of nine
cofounders of Miss Hill Foundation which
is a uk-based charity focused on
reconnecting humanity to nature and
bridging wisdom traditions with
modernity their first film the twelve
released on July 12 2009 teen gives a
voice of the 12 elders who met in
December 2017 at the United Nations
headquarters to co-create a specific
ritual for Humanity and planet Earth you
can find the links in the body below
D'Alessio Foundation calm in the 12th
film calm okay
such powerful trailer such powerful
films so blessed that I was able to come
and watch it twice during screenings in
San Francisco was so good I had to go
back next day to watch it again and that
trailer definitely does it just so many
powerful thoughts there about going back
to simple truths about about money not
being more important than love and trust
about reconnecting with nature teach us
about this film about your foundation in
this film
we have to start by the foundation
you're right because the film is one of
the the four first missions of the
foundation the foundation was created by
nine people like you said nine
individuals from five different
nationalities and the common point
denominator is a spiritual path a
spiritual journey that has taken all of
us to be part of the the same tradition
and you know throughout our journeys our
spiritual journeys throughout the
different rituals that we did or
different dreams or different visions
that we had we were given a life mission
each one individually and when we
realized when we fully integrated the
the enormity of the missions that we
were given we realized we can do it on
our own so we decided to collaborate
fully and and to help each other you
know achieve our missions in this
lifetime so that's how the self
foundation was founded and it was
founded also around certain principles
and values that we were given by the
traditions that that we are coming from
and by our huge respect that we have for
wisdom traditions in general we really
think that wisdom traditions hold a huge
amount of keys for our society so that's
that's for the foundation and so one of
the co-founder as a Peter received this
mission through a series of dreams and
so it was so vivid and so will that yet
to make it happen so it was a our first
mission because of that but we realized
during all our trips and when we are
screening the film that's a lot a lot of
people have received the same messages
so it's really funny to realize that we
are all able to receive and it's like a
broadcast you know
and at some point you take it and you go
for it
so you haven't defined the first mission
it's a first mission
it is a Council of 12 and above so this
mission is to gather 12 elders from all
over the world at united nation and it
happened in 2017 and it was about
recreating a blueprint for humanity for
us to be able to reconnect ourselves to
our true nature to nature but also to
realize that we can't do anything
without our planet Earth so let's be in
tune with in harmony without and so the
film was the natural continuity because
we all the people that actually helped
us and and all the people from the
foundation were so amazed by the level
of generosity and integrity and humility
of these elders who you know for most of
them traveled really out of their
comfort zone and most of them never went
out of there
you know hometowns and in so they had to
take the plane come to New York which is
a pretty hectic city as you know and we
were so fully grateful and in respect of
that that we the film came naturally as
a mission to you know spread the
messages give speech give a voice to
these elders so that they can tell their
truth to the the Western world and not
oh of course the film talks a little bit
about the the ritual at the UN and how
this all happened yeah you are so cool
because you've now done the thing that I
think so many people in the world are
desired to happen which was to get the
ancient these elders together and
put something beyond us into the future
blueprint that will hopefully reconnect
us to our origins to nature and not only
does your view of your you too of the
nine you function like an organism and I
love that about the way that you've
taught me about how you how you work
together all the way to how difficult it
was to to travel to all of these places
to go there with you we operate in such
a similar way since in the sense of our
account has just barely enough money if
not it has a void and then we can just
pay it off and what we need and then go
to the next so you guys are doing the
same thing with your plane tickets just
not enough to go then enough pops in and
you go and sometimes you don't even have
a connection to the to the elder in that
area yet and so and then you have to get
get them to come New York these are in
there's trust building that has to
happen with this whole process taking
240 hours of film that you've collected
and bringing that down to 75 minutes is
the film length 77 these are very very
complex things and I think it's again
it's really important when you watch the
77th minute film to realize all these
hard components that you've put in your
your energy into to make it happen but
we feel really grateful because it was a
real journey for all of us we learned so
much about ourselves and about the world
we are living and the one we would like
to live
every experience has been taken so
strongly in ourselves that because of
that we feel now that we are able to do
more we can give more and the most
important is to be able to through this
channel being able to give back to the
elders because you have so much to give
to our yeah
working for humanity day and night they
are fantastic they are so dedicated so
it's time now maybe just to hear what
they have to say they are just loved
yeah and and you know we first of all
yeah we we they did the whole blueprint
thing we just got them to the Uni and
then the rest is the blessing in that is
that Dee where were just instruments
right
we were just letting the universal plans
actually happen because the universe has
perfect plans for us we're just in
resistance of that you know we're
fighting very hard for disciplines not
to actually happen but when you let it
you know when you let yourself go into
being fully guided then the purpose
kicks in and then what happens is
absolutely magical and it's so powerful
that you need you you know to
acknowledge that the plan is perfect
what is planned for us is absolutely
perfect and so that's that to me is the
most unbelievable learning when you have
to let go for a full year and as you
were saying function in a unique
organism meaning you have to let go of
your personality some house so that you
function as a whole and and that means
you know to let go of a lot of
expectations lots of beliefs so that you
can actually function as such a level in
terms of vibrations that things come to
you and that when things come to you
you're being constantly tested by by the
universe are you actually motivated
enough to keep on letting go
and keep the universe guide you and so
you're tested all the time and that
group dynamic has been an amazing
experience because I think it's way more
difficult to do it alone you know the
group thing is something absolutely
crucial that we've learned from wisdom
traditions as well you know yes I really
believe in communities they really feel
that we are something but we're not
single so at the same time so maybe we
can create a little Empire for ourselves
but what it is going to give to the
world nothing so they are looking at
their choice and free will with the lens
of is it going to be good for people who
are Romney and is it going to be good
for the planet
so those three aspects are really
important and also looking at isn't
going to be good for the eight next
generations this part's so beautiful to
think of in every decision with I eight
generations out this is gonna be good
for them yeah yes that's the actual
definition of responsibility through the
lens of integrity if you're responsible
of course you're gonna think seven
generations ahead you know it seems
natural it makes sense right yeah
responsibility for each other for for
the planet yeah for the future
generations that don't have a stake in
the conversation today but that they
really want a sustainable place though
to live yeah that and also you know the
because those in in those traditions I
mean the younger generations are as
important and as active because they you
know they're conscious so they they
co-create by their thoughts by the way
they speak by it's not about it's not
just about action it's when you are you
you create you manifest this reality so
by setting an example of you know taking
every decision seven generations ahead
of course you you set the example for
the younger generations and you set up a
culture where things are clear
transparent
in integrity and and and interconnected
of course because everything is how many
generations have been since the Pyramids
of Giza you know 4,500 years an era so
like when that's what we're talking you
can we make things that transcend our
only timelines yeah on the planet that
build a beautiful but I want it I want
to hit on a couple things with you guys
there's some it within the within the
within the blueprint it's in in many
ways the ancestral wisdoms that are
being communicated from all different
parts of the world are saying the same
thing that we have disconnected from
nature and because of that we have so
many of the issues that we have in our
world when children are born into
metropolis is there's a new there's
light pollution they don't ever see the
stars the just go to a grocery store
purchase food and don't even have hands
in the soil growing food ever that these
disconnections from understanding and
the gratitude for the air at the water
that food the interconnectedness of it
all
is a recipe for dysfunction in in our in
our world and so I think that that how
then does does then that tie into what
the blueprint that dysfunction that we
just mentioned how does that tie into
what you have to that blueprint
so the you know what the elders did on a
spiritual plane is all about potentials
it's all about probabilities it's all
about opening Quantum's so that things
so that you know out of 1 billion
directions that we could say the we are
most likely guided to the the few
directions where things go better that's
what they did
so they shifted our state our potentials
if there's a billion options and maybe
some of the trajectories were less food
less sing less ideal they shifted it
towards the more ideal trajectory yeah
that's what we think they did they told
us you know from the beginning that we
have like 5 to 6 years to change our way
to behave and so the goal with this
ritual was to give to give us a lot of
possibilities to be successful meaning
that it's not to go in revolution from
one point to the same point but it's to
find a way for human beings to go in a
state of evolution to create a new path
for all of us
and so this journey has been created in
the spiritual level with the elders two
years ago and so now it's just about
what we can do in our farm attic and
practical world to you know take
everything from the spiritual and to
create for us to grow in this physical
no yes yeah it's so very inclusive right
the the ritual in itself includes all
humanity but now these these elders and
all the wisdom traditions
they're turning to us and says sir now
let's take responsibility you know let's
all the potential that has been created
let's have it trickle down and actually
manifest in in this world and that's
what we're trying to do with other
projects that we have such as the
holistic vision symposium we're trying
to manifest in this reality a culture
that includes the values and the
spiritual sacredness of the wisdom
traditions and sacredness being
something that is absolutely not
dogmatic or religious it's just
connection connection to nature
connection to the universe and
connection to your true nature
and so of course they're always
extending a helping hands because
there's there's so much to learn from
them but they're expecting us to take
action and it's not just about a ritual
and then things will change by
themselves we need to take action and we
firmly believe that the action needs to
go through collective intelligence we
think that the the clustering the abyss
the the reactions in silos is something
that is all paradigm we need to take
responsibility and and start by the fact
that we need to acknowledge our own
impact on this reality we need to
discover the the spiritual dimension of
the constant creation because of your
thoughts because of your words and it's
not just about the actions you do it's
about the way you wake up the way you
behave the the whole day and it's and
it's it needs a constant vigilance in
our kind of societies because you're so
triggered by so many things with a
change of you know cultural perspectives
or cultural environments and things
could get easier including you know
community work because communities is
the best safety net in terms of humility
and integrity
it's about that it's realizing that we
are all interconnected and not only into
human beings but also with living beings
and the VCG earth so as soon as you are
interconnected you can fill the other
one and you can be in communication and
create together and creating together is
fantastic and the the person there's a
thing in the United Society now the
words are perverted you know a word like
spirituality has been perverted but even
community you know community is used the
somehow as silos the people getting
together and in sticking together
because they have common energy interest
and then they feel different from the
others we're talking about community of
the living right so that includes
everything this guy is part of my family
and hopefully I'm part of his so
community should be so opened that it
totally changes the stakes with he we
the filters that we see things with at
the moment
yeah it's about collective and called
cooperation
there's there's a couple things here um
one of them is that the from the this
overall blueprint the the shift in all
the in the possible outcomes of the
trajectory of Earth in a more positive
direction that then there needs to be
like we were just describing these these
changes that happen in the physical
world so our co-creation not inside not
in silos but together in harmony with
nature and then projects like yours so
you have the twelfth film though now
this holistic vision simplicity vision
symposium is another one yeah that so
teach us about this project and then
maybe this project can act as a and the
film and your other projects that are in
connect maybe as also as blueprints are
somewhat of ideas for other people too
to see us things we can build in the
physical world that can help with
shifting of the trajectory in here so
the first phase of the recipient
symposium happened in Barcelona last
November and we took the same blueprint
as the concern so there were 12 groups
instead of 12 people there were 12 group
of 12 people and in the middle there was
above so it was a group sacred in
reality in meaning the elders from the
council working to instill in every
topics topics the connection the
connectivity for people to realize that
if you are working on integral Health's
integral health you have to find the
connection also with a sacred not only
with the physical aspect of yourself and
the integral health can't work without
the water topic always about the
permaculture topic or the community or
the love and righteousness so it's about
really creating a platform a council but
with one 144 people from all over the
world from 38 different countries
working as one to work on solutions
to help humanity to move forward and to
maybe find a way to get rid of the
issues with the visa planet and with
themselves between themselves and so
they worked from them they worked on a
platform to put together the project and
the next team podium is going to happen
in Barcelona next December
yeah the holistic vision symposium is
based on two essential principles for us
first the the fact that you need to see
everything in a holistic way because
everything is interconnected so you need
to look at the global picture and
realize that you can't solve it just one
thing isolated you need to you know see
and perceive all the environment and all
the different issues that come with it
and then to be able to come up with
solutions that are actually sustainable
on several generations then you need to
instill the sacredness in there and the
sacredness is just those values the the
love the integrity the responsibility
the joy the evolution I'm sure and I'm
forgetting some and then and in
principles that you know those
traditions can give us about the actual
fabric of reality and quantum physics
really are getting closer and closer to
unity fully reuniting with the divisions
of these traditions because we're
talking about the actual fabric of
reality so if you want to come up with
solutions that make sense you need to
understand what's happening behind the
scene behind what's happening in your
brain and how the brain presents how the
world is for you so these are the two
strong principles of the holistic vision
symposium and we are aware that it's
just a template and that
you know there are many people in the
world who could actually enhance what
we've set up as a starter and make it
even more efficient and optimal so you
know again collaboration is essential
that this is very open and the solutions
that the group came are coming up with
will be open sourced and shared the goal
is to be scalable shareable and
affordable for any community in the
world that's Steve that's the big aim
via for us to come together and even in
the in the film there's a moment where
the elders are talking about the
importance of feeling the connection to
the interconnectedness of everything and
once you do that and you feel that and
you know that then everything changes
your everything changes and you're in
your essence in your spirit and that to
be able to have those settings in the
physical reality that we live in where
we can congregate people to tap into the
interconnectedness where we can think
about the earth as a living organism
just like our body is this beautiful
piece of art the earth itself has organ
systems it is a beautiful piece of art
and if they're interconnected just like
ours are and so to have these awakenings
is critical for the collective doodle to
make the the moves seven generations out
let's let's also explain about the so
many different countries of places on
the on the on the planet where the
the tribe there you guys added such a
good amount of humor to into the film
and I'm I'm so happy that that you did
you know pulling into Manhattan and it's
like there are no trees here and yeah
and and yeah very similarly to the the
boats the two from Botswana saying that
you know we eat from from Earth now if
you don't have money you die
and it's these moments that you can be
put so simple there wisdoms are put so
simple and we can we come back and ask
them questions about these wisdoms but
Botswana Gabon in Africa Japan Alaska
Colombia Mexico Colombia Nepal Australia
Australia I think we're good
there's so many that yeah so we so we
have to be clear with the the film do
you or the Council of the twelve are
they're all elders from wisdom
traditions but they're not they're not
representing their tradition or their
people or we were brought to them and
maybe we'll talk about that how we were
brought to them at one point but we were
brought to them because they each of
them embodies a very specific spiritual
key the two elders from Bushmen are a
joy and simplicity the elder from Japan
is determination and precision the the
elder from Mexico is the womb of
creation so they all have that spiritual
key that they fully embody when you
you're with them you can feel the
vibration the exact vibration of joy or
precision it's it's full-on mine and so
by coming together at these specific
keys just clicked in together in a
perfect you know puzzle and that opened
ups they did the vast potential that
they had access to when they did their
ritual and send their intentions so
we all we often have the question why
these countries why isn't there someone
from you know my country and it's not
about the country it's about the the
individuals and so and this is for one
council I mean it doesn't mean that
there couldn't be any other council in
the world doing exactly the same thing
this one happened and it happened with
these people because they were meant to
do this one ritual and that is that is
important for us to to precise it's not
about representing anything it's about
representing a specific quality and of
course a huge amount of humidity
the keys were so cool that yeah each of
them have this key yeah yeah so if is
they're so simple in that way to express
themselves it's not because they have a
simple mind but it's because it's really
well-organized meaning that they are
embodying is a primal journey from oral
tradition they have no dogmas what they
received is direct from their own
connections from nature from their
direct experience and there's one
thing's for sure we haven't found the
fear you know the fear quality in those
tribes it's like it's not it's not there
because it's about love and fear is your
positive love so everything they are
doing is a new experience
you are losing like sensei okie from
Japan he lost all his family during the
war is not saying it was big trauma is
saying it was my biggest experience
when the two Bushmen are sleeping you
know in the airport is they are not oh
my god they could break my leg
yes so it's so much joy you know yeah
and it's about our so you are going to
put your step forward and what you want
to create in your life isn't going to be
a bad fear about anger always about joy
and simplicity and there's a you were
talking about it interconnectedness and
people have maybe it's hard for them to
understand what the you know what could
be the actual consequence of that if you
make it very simple when you actually
understand and experience the concept of
interconnectedness you're not alone
anymore and so and because your soul is
is overstressed by the feeling that is
produced by your brain of being alone
being different from the others and
you're so very alone in this world that
you you're in fear you're in sadness you
you you know have all these negative
sentiments and feelings that are due to
this belief that the you're all alone
when you feel into when you tap into
interconnectedness you're never alone
you could be the only man on the planet
you're with the planet you know and
that's
that is the the biggest maybe the
biggest difference between being in
separation and and feeling
interconnected it's the happiness it
just comes with the package because
yeah so it's almost as though than the
children that are or that are born or
have the full connection to the
interconnectedness and then the the kind
of the art the more artificial like
things like metropolis is that we built
potentially like do things like fragment
there in Turkey there and their
connection their interconnectedness and
so that's why it feels as though when we
go to do things like and now science US
Forest therapy you know this like oh you
can go and decrease your stress levels
by coating to the forest it's like and
most people only go out feel a deep
interconnectedness to to source to
nature towards to where our origins are
from and when when you do things like go
and talk to the to the elders and they
say this
which feels as though it's it's been
here with us and it's been forgotten and
that that's what it yeah yeah
is every I've accessed to a feat of
knowledge and what they are giving us
now through this film but has other
initiatives around the world and they
are all fully fantastic because it's
retimed to move together on our with the
same goal in the same aim but what they
are telling us is we can act differently
and being happy we can act differently
and feeling better so yeah and it's you
know the in our position we're really
and you said it we're not about going
back to Hudson and you know living in
the forest well I might live in the
forest but maybe not in a hut
not an ice cave the goal is to actually
there is a possibility of you know
reaching a truly beautiful modernity
that you know it's just connected to
what's happening and that modernity you
know when you go to Australia they tell
you that when you're born and this this
is what you're saying when you're born
you have hundreds of abilities hundreds
more than 300 and then through
conditioning through education in in in
Western school through parenting or
through whatever happens to you during
your life in in traditional or in modern
societies like ours you forget all about
these things because you're being told
that it's it that it doesn't exist so
the older things that when you're a kid
you know that you're able to do then
everyone you like to see in your
invisible friend and then you know all
the adults tell you yeah it's gonna pass
you know and it does pass and then you
get to the point where you're an adult
and then you maybe you have one ability
or maybe two and and you don't even know
what
and there's nothing you can do right so
the how about a modern age where we get
full access to these abilities we meet a
lot of people who are into biohacking
and and and then this is all great this
is all very exciting but there is a you
know the true biohacking is going back
to that knowledge and not being
conditioned into forgetting what we can
do in our true nature you know and of
course not being the victim of food
systems and and yes whatever kills you
know the actual physiological ability to
that our perfect body has when when it's
born you know and it's also to get rid
of the last addiction maybe the humanity
I had access to it's a this compulsive
way of wanting more spirituality so
going from one ritual to another one to
find more experience instead of being in
the presence living it's a sacred time
you have with this sacred plant or the
people around you to work with and if
that integrated meaning it's taking the
lessons for watch what you got so
instead of okay this weekend I'm doing
that and then we can after and I thought
about that I want to do it it's where
you are going to go because you are
called for it so it's about yeah first
yeah what you can hear into yourself and
get rid of all the desire from the
others and at some point you have access
to what you have to do and maybe it
could open much more knowledge for
everyone yeah people are all craving for
visions and but the true spiritual
lessons are in little details in in the
daily life what you get in visions might
take a year
to actually integrate and understand but
do you understand and through things
that are given to you on a daily basis
very little details that you need to be
vigilant for so that and that's the
beauty of spirituality it's not about
being hammered you know through an
experience that it's gonna leave you
shell-shocked for three days and then
you get to another you know yes yes it's
something way deeper than that even in
our images right before we started we
were talking about how the tripod is the
same tripod that we have here that you
use as you traveled same brand and
whatnot and and those some people call
you know beautiful synchronicities the
spiritual essence that appeared other
people say these are just oh it's just
you know mathematical and sometimes they
align when they don't align you don't
mention them when they do align you do
mention them there's these yeah so
there's always there's always this
spirituality tries to like push an edge
of knowledge and understanding and then
science kind of creates a container of
hypothesizing it and then trying to
prove it and I think that that science
and spirituality will work more
harmoniously moving forward in the
future
I want to also just mention what you
said earlier these keys and how like joy
and simplicity were key and the womb was
a key determination was a key from the
different elders and I I love those it's
like that if we can become masters at
these skill sets that you know that we
come through with this with this purpose
that that so many people feel like
they're disconnected from their North
Star from their purpose and how can we
you know like we're saying how can we
co-create a collective social fabric
that enables more people to connect with
nature as well as connect with their
purpose on a frequent basis on and every
human gets that
basis and I'm this is this is this is
again this is this thing that keeps
occurring on the show we have guests and
we talked about co-creating this
collective future and then we have to go
and build it in the physical world and
it's very difficult to figure out how to
you got to build a system that
obsoletes the old system and entices
people to come and partake and play in
the in the new system and so things like
the film things like the holistic vision
symposium and things like the what we've
other people are building we got it
the I think these are the these are the
things that we're building in the
physical world that catalyze the instead
of just the five to seven your spin that
stays in the same place of suffering and
both those upward attractor gets upward
yeah so that says a first step is to
just stop one minute and stop relying on
someone else on something else and
accept to be without own on our own and
realize that when we are on our own we
can maybe receive some messages so
technology can be fantastic as it's
super important to have great tools but
our using them is the most important I
think a phone and you know doing things
emails noticing wait but every time you
can be on your own just stop your phone
and be with yourself and sometimes it
can be a great void and sometimes
tensions or frustrations or emotions can
really wake up looking at them accepting
them because they are part of us if
they're coming through so so just
looking accepting and realize that okay
now what do I want what I want is that
that
and really to be cautious of what you
want because what you want has to be
simple and it's also as a master's
daughter said joining the council is
also when you have n1 intent is not to
say okay I want to be joyful but put to
be joyful I need to be married before
this time that at this point I will be
joyful if you want to be joyful here and
happy here you have to put intention to
be happy and after that to leave the
flow guiding you wherever you have to go
and at this point you are going to
realize at some point that the journey
you add to access to your goal was
already with happiness and joy
oh my gosh yeah for the space yeah four
messages I think so she is saying it's
all about the direct experience yeah if
you want to change their world start
acting but you don't start acting you
don't start to change the world like
that you the foundation is those values
all right I believe I know there are
positive values that would change the
world I'm gonna apply them in my daily
life and be in integrity with it look at
myself apply those values or you know
sometimes not apply those values and
when it happens and try to change things
and through habit through you know being
an integrity and really doing it you can
see the world changing around you you
can see you on to us yes this is the
first way to act we're talking about the
the science the probabilities and you're
about synchronicities right when when
the only thing that you can say to that
is that when you actually when you have
a synchronicity and you begin to
acknowledge it not saying well it's just
a coincidence but actually name it and
say it's a synchronicity and this
synchronicity has a purpose it is
telling me something and try to you know
learn from it or act from it in in
guidance with the synchronicity then
what happens is that those
synchronicities they multiply they come
you know I
just more often and then they they're
constant and that is a mathematical
model that is absolutely exponential
that proves it's a proof of concept it's
not coincidental if you have the right
culture and the right you know apply the
the right amount of lessons then you
vibrate a little bit higher every day
and then synchronicities just and start
happening all the time and that and
someone is something that you cannot you
know undermine under mathematical
theories it just it is right yes oh good
is we to be and after that to be able to
do so to do is not to say oh this one
has not done that so I don't have to do
it you know the goal is to recognize
what you have to do and to do it even if
your neighbor is not doing it without
judging him because we who cares you
know it's you think and that important
also the community is as soon as you are
and you don't need to be recognized by
anyone to be at this point you can do
things and realize that doing is going
to teach others it's not about teaching
it's about doing and if you do people
are going to be oh wow it makes its work
let's go for it
you so we threw our thought and into
action
in guidance towards our North Star we
can identify when we can become more and
more aligned with our purpose that these
little potentially these little
spiritual indicators that we are more
and more aligned with our product with
their purpose show up and we pay we stay
vigilant and pay attention to them and
then it more and more doors open up
we keep continue going more and more
towards path so beautiful oh yes we just
need to precise that this comes with a
part of letting go so yes without any
expectations because the path is not
gonna be what you expect and the gift
and the guidance are gonna lead you
through you know hoops that you wouldn't
have gone through the two weeks prior
but as you let go and you you understand
the concept the whole process of if I
let go whatever happens I take it as a
lesson the outcome yes will be better
than what I could have done because
again the universe is a better planet it
plans on you know things that are way
more ambitious that that we can fathom
in our individuality so it comes you
know it comes with a an amount of
letting go you toll it at the very
beginning the the way we found those
elders was through total faith and it's
a survey yeah it wasn't just about the
money it was we don't we have no clue of
who these people are there are seven
billion people in the planet and even
though we were heavily guided by the
elders themselves and and of course the
eternal did the universe it you know
when you get into it when you have to
buy tickets you have no money and you
don't know who you're gonna meet there
and then you just take the plane you get
to the airport and then you just are
being led by people that you meet
on-site you know that are being thrown
on your path and then and then to get to
the actual
you have to complete maybe two or three
tests as a group in terms of integrity
because you know letting go in our
society it puts a lot of tensions it
puts a lot of pressure on a group yeah
because you know marching at the same
pace in the same direction and vibrating
constantly at a sufficient level when
everything in our world is supposed to
be planned and expected and booked month
ahead and you know is putting so much
pressure that you you're constantly
being tested on that on faith and then
on love for each other and then and then
you're expected to grow because all the
tensions that appear you're creating
them as a group and as an individual so
define them and then work on them so it
doesn't happen in the same way or you
can transform them and grow out of it
and take lessons out of it and then
you're like okay that that test is it's
through boom you're meeting a new person
that oh maybe I know the person that
you're looking for and then you know you
go through another test until you're
there and and the elder tells you well
you know welcome home we've been
expecting you the amount of letting go
is not easy every day but it's
absolutely satisfying because again the
way it's planned is absolutely
mind-blowing they did the amount of
magic when you live your life like that
is much more higher than the amount of
stress and tension and fear that can be
generated just by the process right yeah
the fear is usually what you've created
inside of yourself and so we had that
during the film process because Lucy
with the filmmaker and the co-director
and also co-founder was resisting a lot
and also had all the you know when you
are filmmaker when you are creating a
films it's really we step and you have
to do things with the right milestones
and we couldn't do that we couldn't tell
what we were going to do the day after
or where we were going to go and so
everything was about being spontaneous
and being free and it was beautiful
process and where that also in the
post-production because when we decided
after that the film is going to be given
Bob for free before months who were
thinking maybe we should find a
distributor maybe we should find a
distribution way to do those things and
it was not coming to us we were okay
nothing is happening until the point it
was obvious yes this film is for
everyone because it the elders and it's
knowledge from the elders for Humanity
so it's for everyone so it has to be
free and that's why we decided to
translate it in seven different
languages before the launch to be able
to spread the word more and more and we
are asking also everyone was going to
look at the film too if they want to
translate it in their own language to
let us know and it's a film of everyone
yeah the Lucy Lucy has so many stories
about the how hard it was as a filmmaker
to actually you know
alright well leaving tomorrow but even
the theme of the film when she signed up
for it she was short it was gonna be a
film about nature so she was going you
know on long trips to film nature and
then one elder after the other she
started and she tells that story so I
hope I'll do it justice but she started
realizing that you know these elders
they were saying kind of the same thing
and they were saying very deep stuff
that resonated with her and throughout
that whole process at one point she
realized that the theme had totally
changed you know it was about the others
it was about connection with nature but
through a spiritual lens to it and then
she had a groundbreaking experience in
Colombia and I think where she realized
that
the negative feelings that she could
have for herself and keep for herself
she because the the dealer told her she
realized that even if she wasn't you
know communicating about our negative
feelings even if she wasn't you know
throwing everything at everyone's face
and really keeping them for herself she
realized that it was going straight to
the earth into the universe because you
know they absorb everything and at that
point it was groundbreaking for us then
I I need to stop feeling sorry for
myself because this this is actually
affecting the earth and the others you
know it was a really profound revelation
for her which helped her way more on
their way for the rest of the film
because they I mean I Deanna
it was absolutely crazy the stories and
the amount of letting go on the trips
wasn't yeah this story about not having
the room at the United Nations as well
until just a couple days before three
days beforehand and you nine had to work
together as co-founders and so we were
not nine because we she was traveling
Elizabeth wanna sure so we were yeah and
so we were all together and we realized
that these points that we didn't get
such room yet after one year of people
telling us no problem you are going to
have it tomorrow and everyone was
supposed to arrive the day after so we
will yet to move forward so we decided
to stop our phones and computer just
look at what was happening and we
realized at this point that the sim of
the year was unity and because we were
really working together so well we
thought of that who are unity and at
this point it was obvious that no if not
we would have had that room so we
decided to put everything on the table
for eight hours with a lot of tears and
things that are and at some point you
know it was like everyone was in peace
and in peace videos us also and feeling
really this it's not even a sensation
it's like a connection of unity and at
this point it was a cloudy day the Sun
opened up even on the blue skies we were
on to something so we opened our
computer and we received the news Iowa
after before an email from the Ecuador
initiative and they were telling us so
nicely that video line with what we are
doing and they would be happy to give us
the room and also a security pass so
it's about working on ourselves to have
access to what we want to have
yeah the need to be in flow and and as
soon as you're not in flow as sooner
things are not coming you know to you
then you have to address it it's
something within yourself and it wasn't
just the room at the UN it was the venue
at the assemblage for the first day but
it was also visas yeah we had the the
elder from Siberia was stuck in Korea to
get a visa because of course if you're
Russian difficult to have a visa for the
the US and then the boots one again is
the maybe a day and a half before the
before that happened we're still stuck
in Botswana trying to get visa who flies
them by from the mistletoe yeah so to
have access to the visa and they were
not even sure that they were going to
have it and and and that's the beauty of
the process because you could think well
they found the masters or they found the
elders so everything's gonna be you know
in flow and everything's gonna happen in
and until the last minute you are you
have tests yes just to you know and and
those tests are not punishment they're
indications that you're not in flow mmm
or not sufficiently or that you there's
an opportunity for you to learn
something new so it's all good you know
but it's can be stressful
I love the tests of faith on the journey
to the to the Northstar that's so
important and there's so many of us face
that and to see it in a positive lens
and a growth-oriented lens and a lessons
oriented lens and a test of faith lens I
think is so crucial I want to ask you
both does it when we look at what's
happening on this on this planet on a
macro level does it from both from both
of your perspectives as well some of the
elders perspectives this is seem like
there is a fight happening between light
and dark forces between evil and good
forces
it may be not a fight you know it's
about the balance everything in the
universe about balance so it's a right
amount of each one and they are both to
be here is that important and so right
now it's it's really about yes
looking at where we are at and realized
that the state of the planet is the
state we are - because everything is
factored so all the bad things we are
doing on ourselves meanings about sorts
the all those things you know I'm not
taking care of ourselves and everything
if I doing the same to the planet so to
be able to shift this paradigm
let's begin by earth first let's respect
ourselves respect what we have to do
what we have to to embody and at this
point the planet also is going naturally
like by chance to recover because we are
going to change our behaviors because we
are going to be centered in the line
yet a whole fight between light and
darkness is separation again it's it's a
it's a human concept they everything
dances in the universe light and
darkness are in a dance they're very
close partners and they're very much in
love the the moment we are knowledge
that we all have darkness within
ourselves that it's a possibility of
growth yes that and it cannot be all
light or all darkness and then it's the
subtle balance then everything has a
meaning of everything makes sense you
know so there is the there is the in in
our feeling definitely in an imbalance
but it's it's not about evil it's about
ignorance it's the and the the root
causes that separation between the
sacred and the material in the film
master hotend talks about it with a
hypocrite as the the doctor he says he
was a very spiritual person but then his
students only took the physical side of
is a of his teachings and and left year
did and that is very symbolic of a
modern age that that unification between
sacred and and material is absolutely
necessary and is as necessary as the the
dance between light and darkness yeah
we just said so many times seems like
the I'm the dystopian the utopia are on
the field of possibilities and that do
more things like the blueprint and
building in the physical world ways to
connect deeper to the interconnectedness
so that we can go towards the more
utopic future and that it's not it
doesn't seem like it's guaranteed it
doesn't seem like a civilizations
guarantee it's collapsed before and that
it doesn't so we have what we have we
have to embody action into the world
yeah it's a guarantee yeah
it's about us now what we're going to do
and what we want to give as a legacy to
our kids and that super important
realize that we had to turn points if
who has so many people one more aware
working as one even if you are working
with different organizations respecting
and promoting the others Sony because
it's a special time and it's now we have
to wake we have to be on it yeah and
it's not about it can be about but it's
not only about big things no you know
these elders they took an individual
step they just followed to New York and
then did their ritual the it was never
about you know filling up Wembley
Stadium and and and doing something
tremendous they did it in humanity very
desperately the UN wasn't aware at all
that this was happening everything was
really you know private and so it was of
course that I mean if we keep on on
individually putting all the
responsibilities of change on the others
and on organizations on governments on
then we're screwed
this needs to F do the change needs to
come from the base and go up it needs to
come from us individually and so if
you're asking what kind of actions can I
do change yourself
start with that you know have a daily or
weekly moment for yourself to actually
look yourself in the mirror and see what
you can change to embody positive values
that will change the world by doing so
you are in action and if everyone or a
number of people because there's a
tipping point we only need three or four
percent of the overall population to
actually change for everything to tip
into something else that's mathematical
you did there is a theory on that that
amount of people that are going towards
positive change were creating body fully
those those sculptures and are highly
conscious they could sip everything you
know and energetically so it's feasible
but people need to start by themselves
and and because when they do so they set
an example for their kids they said you
know giving giving that gift to your kid
that culture is way bigger than giving
in a college education mmm
it is something that will change their
lives forever and will change the world
doesn't mean that they don't need to go
to college of course they need an
education but they need a set of values
that our culture doesn't provide our
culture is all about brainwashing those
kids and and us in the same package and
not make them think of these values they
our culture is about wanting more about
being greedy about being and and we can
feel and that's why we all need to be
very optimistic because you can feel
that it's the right time for that change
you can meet when you start doing those
little things that little work on
yourself then you meet more and more
people that are exactly on the same path
and then at one point you're getting
goose bumps because you know that we're
millions that believe that it's feasible
yes 300 ish million isn't it exactly and
we're living in that time it's so
exciting
we
you have the possibility to change
things and the beautiful things also
they taught us that the elders is the
fact that everything you are changing
into yourself deeply not only the
behavior you know but deeply you are
implementing that in your lineage
so everything you are learning as a
quality is going to go directly to your
kids for even for you you not have
anything to do it going to be directly
to them but also to your ascent and
lineage your parents conference if even
if they are not here anymore
you know the solar are still working and
so you are implementing in your lineage
also qualities you can learn and grasp
and integrate during this lifetime so
it's quite something yeah hmm we got
this we got this
mmm
and okay on July 12th worldwide release
of the film and in seventh already in
seven different languages yes and the
potential for people to set up viewing
parties to watch together it's very much
so like a like a communal experience to
have with people to like talk about
afterward to yeah we want the experience
to be like the the ancestral fire you
know that you that you'll gather in a
circle around and and then talk for
hours and and and and you know do the
telling of the stories and so we really
want that film to be accessible so that
people can make it there so yes it will
be available for streaming will be
available for downloads in seven
languages and the downloads will include
a filmed Q&A a more extensive written
Q&A and then maybe guidelines to
organize your own screenings and and
maybe something else we're thinking
about programs for kids as well so I
love that so that they could actually
you know watch the movie and then
interact with it
but the goal is for people yeah but as
soon as they resonate with the film they
spread it around they share the link but
they also organize screenings of their
own and and they have a communal a
community experience around it because
we guarantee we've been doing what three
months of pre screenings we guarantee
that the experience of watching this
film on a proper screen with a proper
sound with people is is tremendous
compared to watching it on a laptop with
headphones the difference it's exactly
like in meditation when you meditate at
all not the same thing that when you
meditate with a hundred and fifty
persons the level of vibration is not
the same so we encourage people to
actually have lived that experience and
we do so by providing at the same time a
platform a community platform well
they'll be able to pinpoint
on a map where they're organizing
screenings and then have those community
slots be fully open to dialogue so that
people after seeing the movie can
actually exchange and then they can
exchange you know in between communities
all around the world and hopefully that
will be billed at the start of a
collective intelligence meaning people
getting drawn to action can actually you
know start engaging as communities and
come up with solutions that are local or
that are global whatever you know their
aspiration is but our you know the
biggest problem for us about the
sustainable development goals for
example is that it's very difficult for
the common people to embrace the those
goals they it's all about institutions
about the you know global objectives we
want people to consider those goals
there's and that you know from
communities to communities hey how can
we address you know a sustainable
development goal six about water what
can we do locally together and how can
we find solutions that you know take
into account what these traditions say
about the values and principles how can
we instill that in so that we're sure
the solution will be an integrity with
the rest of the universe so that's
what's gonna happen with the film at
launch thank you for asking
yeah and there's all ready to donate to
your future endeavors is available also
to donate to all of the different
indigenous tribes themselves and because
they themselves have done incredible
things preserving their lineages through
your help so things like that are really
important also the all the extra content
that you have those two hundred forty
hours we were talking about to put those
into because I saw little bits of stuff
that wasn't in the film and some of the
you know and some of the trailer
sequences I don't
extras nugget rights and those nuggets
are making me so interested in you know
in in even the full-length interviews of
all of the indigenous leaders that would
be so cool so I'm so really excited for
that content and trying to please help
fund the foundation we have a we have a
hope that you know as the film is it's
free to download we have a hope that
people will understand that you know
giving a buck or two could you know take
this really further on the on the road
with all our projects you know we really
think that this film should be available
for free but then anything that you know
it can help us it's fully welcome we
need to preside also that all the
cofounders of the foundation are are not
being paid to do this it was is part of
the the values and the principles that
we embody idea at the foundation and so
nothing comes a in the pocket for the
moment maybe one day we'll see and and
yeah any any help is absolutely
priceless for us yeah and it's not only
about people who are looking at the film
if companies wants to help we can do
great things with companies also so and
other foundations since we've been there
we were not for profits not so long ago
but now we're charity we're we're a big
boy so we have a big girl you know we
can actually exchange with the
foundations as well because who has so
helped you know the two first years it
was about our savings and some personal
friends our own family friends and they
were so just amazing but now we would
like to do that you know to expand a bit
more and to be sure that's not always
the same we were supporting the projects
true because they are for everyone at
the end
yeah your massive role models for me and
there's so many others so we're very
great oh thank you no we're having
discussions here about the template
right about the optimal way to be well
again it's difficult you know we have
we're having days where we're not that
optimal and we're not that in flow and
we're in doubt and we're failing being
tested exactly and and it's part of the
process you cannot be you know at your
highest level all the time otherwise
you'd be enlightened right which is the
goal but it's one step at a time and
that's that's I think the the biggest
tool that we have one perfect step at a
time asking you asking your intuition or
your connection what is the right thing
to do not the good not the wrong the
right thing in integrity just one step
at a time and your next perfect one the
next perfect one and then life gets kind
of magical and it does but life is hard
and it's part of the magic yeah because
we are here to learn so we need tests
yes find the solutions from Buddhism and
to have new tests so it's it's constant
yes mhm yeah the the spirit leveling up
on its way to the North Star and having
the the challenges as lessons along the
way Ron and I have had our fair share
that we've gotten through on the way and
big lessons and
really beautiful seeing them as as that
it's like in spiritual code it's kind of
it's beautiful to see it that way and
you've talked a little bit about what
you've been doing and you know those
past month and years and we're very
grateful for that as well I mean it's
all part of the the same big human
project so thank you for your active
participation both of you in there thank
you and thank you for having being in
the flow to have access the first time
of to the film you know guess we're
already there the first guest at this
point people were arriving it and my
phone wrong and was you saying okay this
told me that I should meet you okay come
and you arrived with your bike on top of
this in yeah yeah biking in San
Francisco is mind-blowing to me that's
crazy and it was amazing to have you at
the screening so yeah it's great thank
you in the second so good that he has to
come back for four seconds and then the
next night I love I love it and bring
other people you know the first
screening in the in the or the first
screening tour in the u.s. we had people
follow us for like two or three days and
it was amazing because you know that we
totally vibrated with them but they
would they just they were feeling good
with the with the group dynamic and and
they were totally aligned with it so
they just stuck around and we spent like
three four days together it was crazy
good there have been so many people that
have said to you that that they've had
this vision that they've had this and
you did it you executed it and I love
that and when we first met to that there
was this deep appreciation for ancestral
wisdom and that we ourselves have been
fortunate enough to at least start
interviewing some of the ancestral
elders and and
and you guys have been doing it so
you're doing that in the film form we do
it in this interview form there's a lot
of cool synergy that I feel that we've
talked about feeling moving forward so
what a powerful conversation about the
film about you to the foundation thank
you so much I mean we had I had a great
time I don't know about you yeah you did
it was so grateful for you both and
thank you to all of you for watching
thank you so much and hope you'll enjoy
the the film that's right that's right
everyone thank you so so much for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on what we talked about in this episode
also do check out the links in the bio
below to the CEO foundation as well as
the 12th film and go and watch it set up
the screening parties go and set those
up treat it like those ancestral fires
that we used to have treat it like that
and have more conversation for your
friends your families co-workers people
online on social media about ancestral
wisdom and about building the new
changes that we need in our physical
world for the next steps that we
co-create together support the artists
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world that you believe and support
the missile foundation the links are in
the bio support them please support them
support us help us continue doing cool
things like the show as well all our
links are in the bar below
thank you Ron Vargas for producing and
directing is greatly appreciate it
around
thank you Ron thank you thank you and go
and build the future everyone yes your
dreams into the world we love you very
much Ivo thank you we'll see you soon
thank you
[Music]